Sasha Loftus has been inside the event  we're going to send it over to her now  Sasha things started a little bit late  but apparently as we look over your  shoulder underway now  yes Brian that panel is underway at the  moment between Adam black salt Joe  Lombardo and a few other law enforcement  officials they are speaking about law  enforcement here in Las Vegas and all  around the country and Joe Lombardo and  Adam laxard are speaking about what they  would do if they aren't elected in  November now president Donald Trump is  set to speak at this here once this  panel is over in a little while uh  hopefully or not a little while here  again when this panel concludes again  Joe Lombardo Adam laxalt and a few other  local law enforcement officials are  taking part in this particular panel  here at Treasure Island we will of  course keep you posted on Aaron online  as this event continues tonight  reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus live  local now